[Music]
I'm chair of the Scientific Advisory
Committee of the CFR program integrated
microbial biodiversity or imb what a
program like this does is bring people
together who would not necessarily
ordinarily talk to one another and to
throw out ideas that people haven't
thought about before and what that tends
to do is in many cases it totally
changes the way in which you think about
a problem and what you think you might
be able to do in a different way to
approach the problem the purpose of the
imv program is to get people that you
know think alike but about different
sorts of problems together and to give
us ways to look at problems from new
direction so for example I work on
eukaryotes these complex single cells
other people work on bacteria or viruses
well these things all live in the same
environment they all interact with each
other and it doesn't really do much good
to study one at a time in the
environment trying to understand the
function without studying all of them I
was one of the original members and in
the integrated microbial biodiversity
program but honestly I really wasn't
familiar with the community of
scientists that I was joining and so I
still have very fond memories of the
first meeting which was a planning
meeting and and my mind was blown by the
diversity of research that was going on
and through the meetings with other
members of the IMD I've been exposed to
the incredible diversity of biological
processes that happen in my crew with
eukaryotes and the idea that you can
really think of them as organisms that
have unique physiology unique ways of
interacting with the environment with
each other and that's really helped to
expand my perspectives in my own
research the cfri md program it's really
hard to pinpoint one specific area of my
research that it's impacted because I
really think it's changed the way that I
think and so in that way it changes
every
that I do in the IMD program I get to
work a lot with people that think about
evolution and typically in marine
microbiology we think a lot about marine
microbes and how they affect chemistry
think about their ecology which is why
you find certain organisms where you do
but the IMD program also thinks really
deeply about how organisms evolved and
putting my research my ecology research
and looking at it through this lens of
evolution has been really powerful how
does the world work you know how does
how does microbial life actually work
it's the problem with microbial life is
that the organisms are small you can't
see them but they're also massively
abundant and those and so complicated
right small massively abundant
incredibly important it's hard to put
that together you know so what people do
in the program is just take take slices
of that complexity from different places
and then at the meeting we can put it
together work it work through it and
then figure out you know heart to figure
out how it all fits together and to me
that's I mean what could be better than
that what's the most exciting problem in
biology because we're studying organisms
that haven't been well studied before
these are new discoveries and they're
they are generating questions that
people wouldn't have known to ask and so
that's what excites me about this
program it's really about discovery it's
not about incrementally improving our
knowledge about something that we
already knew about pretty well this is
about discovering something completely
new and unexpected and exciting and
opening up entirely new areas of
research we are studying the invisible
world from many different angles
I think the Edit value of the program is
this this combined big picture what do
protists will do bacteria and what do
virus is there and how these interact
these are studied separately until
actually I dare to say this program
implemented and I am not aware of any
other initiative that would lump all
this together so I believe that in the
end this will be the most important
outcome of this program to provide some
kind of integrated view of this tiny
world down there
[Music]
you